[Music]
you just learned to scuba dive that's
good
8d scuba dad I don't know it's kind of
scary and I got certified last summer
and then I just went again and I was a
little anxious you know Nate and I told
the the scuba guy I said to be honest
with you I'm a little anxious maybe I
shouldn't go down on the deep dive with
everybody and he said just hold my hand
until you feel comfortable down there
well you know I have his hand the whole
time it was like I was like falling in
love with you know how you see those ads
with The Honeymooners holding hands
scuba dive that was me and this guy and
we're like floating through the water
and sink sea turtles and then he checked
my my air tank to make sure I had enough
air like he really cared about me and
checking your air tank who is this perv
what else did he check while you were
down there to check your air that's my
move maybe I don't need to listen up
yeah ladies love that when I go in for
the kill so yeah so this guy you know
this guy right we were down like 60 feet
under the water just floating and I and
I felt like I think there's a like a
soulful connection with me and this guy
I think you get up on the surface and
not so much you see him and you're like
you know what yeah I get it
we're good under above water not so much
sounds like you were getting too much
oxygen you had the right mix of oxygen
is checking my that's called the Conan
but you don't like it when people do it
to you
a little oh no I don't I like to give
not receive
I think way too much about me